well tensions are boiling over across
our northern border on conservative
cable news channels the protest
dominates the attempts to try and crush
down on this protest in ottawa has made
it a rallying cry following suit
republican politicians and even a former
president have taken up the cause we
want those great canadian truckers to
know that we are with them all the way
global interest in the ottawa protest is
being driven by the powerful american
right with claims of big tech censorship
adding a new layer to their efforts
after gofundme shut down the trucker's
online fundraising campaign their
corporate communists are stealing money
i mean this is literally theft by
deception
it all puts ottawa at the center of the
american culture wars which may have
been the strategy all along when u.s
based groups took notice in the early
days
the scale of the level of donations and
the the international interest too seems
to be quite unprecedented kieran
o'connor is a researcher in online
extremism he says interest in the
canadian trucker protest and its
anti-government anti-mandate message has
since spread worldwide at a phenomenal
pace i was able to find evidence of
international support for the original
gofundme link from groups and
communities outside of canada i was able
to find evidence of the gofundme being
shared amongst white supremacist
communities on telegram and after
gofundme pulled the plug an alternative
fundraising campaign raised nearly 5
million dollars in just a few days
many of those donations purport to be
from the u.s many more are anonymous we
need to be very vigilant
about external forces about foreign
interference
and that
that funds which are being collected are
not used for inappropriate purposes
which may indeed undermine public safety
taken with the statements from american
elected officials the former u.s
ambassador to canada sees reason for
serious concern well there's a group now
within the republican party that sees
this differently
and is willing to go cross what i
consider to be a red line
and that red line is to be promoting
disruptive activity
in our neighbor friend and allies
backyard those efforts are no longer
limited to supporting the canadian
protests efforts to recreate the ottawa
convoy and its disruption are now
underway here in washington in cities
across the u.s and right around the
world
donna
jackson proskow in washington thanks